as promised here he is from the buffalo
bills getting set to play
in his first career afc
championship game formerly of the
carolina panthers who he made the super
bowl with he is
josh norman how are you josh
how hey you racist going on but i'm
doing good man doing actually great
actually great josh norman here on the
rich eisen show
what are you you're feeling great i mean
physically emotionally walk me through
this
josh how's it going all things all
things i'm feeling great about i mean
you can't write a better script than
what we are right now um
truly blessed and very faith fortunate
um
enough i think elohim has blessed us in
so many ways but definitely
in this chance this opportunity um of
lifetime in this afc championship game
this week so
um all the things that we have to work
to ourselves up to this point
is is right in our grasp so just gotta
go do it go up there and do our job and
try to take it you know
i asked you this question after you made
your debut
uh with the team in vegas in week four
and you came up with a big
uh takeaway in that game and a big
victory for the bills
early on in the season i asked you you
know you've been around
a team that's been to the super bowl and
how this team looks
um you said you're beginning to just see
some good stuff
what what feeling do you have right now
now that you're a couple days away from
a win away from getting back to the
super bowl
josh you know the feeling hasn't changed
has only
intense intensified itself from
previously you know it's only four teams
remaining
and only two of those in the afc so
one has to beat out the other one and go
to the show
the big dance of them all this is what
we worked for
all the way back in the springtime we
were doing zoom calls
you know and from that going all the way
up into
this week like my goodness yeah
everything is going to be expended
from ourselves this sunday coming up i
mean when you look at all the things
that we've
you know persevered through through
those times and
and this team and how we overcame so
much stuff during this time
i mean others have too but we stayed the
course
um we enact about nothing we kept our
head down and we just kept working
and looking now i mean we have a chance
to do something very special in this
organization so
we don't want to take that lightly and
we want to be respectful of our
opportunity
go out there and do our best now in
retrospect as you're getting ready again
for the afc championship game in kansas
city
josh looking back i'm sure it was a long
flight home i'm sure it was very
difficult
uh did the hail murray help this team in
any way shape or form
losing in that fashion at all
i'm glad you know what people
talk about on sports shows or casters or
analysts anything that have anything to
say about
the the game itself none of that matters
right like to us the ones that actually
go into this
practice every day like the hardest
thing does not be the games
and i want people to understand that
it's during the week
when you're seeing these guys like day
after day and you and you're working and
you're going through
film study and classroom meetings and
getting out there on the field like
during the week the prep coming up to
the game
so the game is just the you know the fun
part of
all the stuff that we put in during the
week and
we start over again the next week and do
it all over again in a new game plan
another week
we don't concern ourselves about what
happened previously
we correct it but we move on i think
when people
hark on things that's just from the
outside perspectives because
that's the only thing they have to talk
about like we don't
like we move on because we have to fight
for another team
and we have to play for the next
opponent and so those things don't ever
like occur to us like we understand we
watch
it from the week we come in on the next
day
and see and correct our mistakes but we
move on after that
so bury that game so what's the
adversity you were just referring to
then where you say that this because
you lost three times one of them to the
team that you're you're playing against
but you could also say those were unique
circumstances in which you actually
played kansas city
when you're saying about a season-long
adversity what are you
what are you referring to well what
we're talking about is injuries
um injuries the co-bit situation playing
a big part for everybody not just us
right um that and then um myself i was
speaking on some of the things that i
had to
you know battle through and persevere
through um
and coming back twice from the hamstring
injury and everybody else that was
dealing with um
you know injuries and stuff like that
normal stuff from every other team but i
just felt that
you know coming here and doing something
here you know my mindset was
already set during the whole season and
then bam
you out you come back in bam you out you
come back in it's just like
wow getting the rhythm but no looking
forward to
you know these opponents that we have
and knowing that okay we got to play our
best game
not last week but this week next
opponent is our best opponent
and so doing that and have that mindset
and stay in the course man
shoot we right about 10 wins in a row i
mean come on
you know like we have to have a mindset
where you got to get rid of that next
one and go on and that
deals that courage and that you know um
how would i say
that ability to go on and fight for more
josh norman here on the rich eisen show
you said uh just a second ago that your
next opponent is your best opponent
you could say that again uh do you guys
right now expect to see patrick mahomes
on sunday
josh norman honestly if we do we do if
we don't we don't
and angles got no show here
but in terms of what that that almost
got me to
not take my glasses off because i need
to see this uh also to hear it so
you're not at all discussing hey you
know do you think mahomes is going to
play you're that's not even a
conversation
amongst you right now like i told you
it's our next opponent
because our next opponent we're going to
you know go through the
um the proper challenge that we
regularly go to during the week and the
game plan and
and get ready for our next opponent so
if he's out there he's out there
um if the other guys the receivers the
the tight end and the running backs they
out there we're gonna scout them too
and what they like to do best um i don't
if we don't put nobody over nobody else
that's for sure not here but you know
our mindset is to go win the game
and they keep opponents and their
targets the ones that are their bell
cows
got a plan for them and whether he's
there or not i can't
you know we'll see and
uh you know how much can we learn from
uh the previous
outing we just saw obviously the bucks
take care of the saints after losing to
them twice
you played a week six game was supposed
to be on thursday night got postponed to
the following week
due to all the aforementioned covet
craziness
uh and they ran the ball all over the
place uh against the bills
what what can we what can you take from
that
film-wise and uh and use in the afc
championship game
josh norman well i'm gonna say this
we're not the same team
we're good football team working become
a great football team
uh and having that montage behind our
name you know uh we're cooking on all
cylinders and
in a day i'm gonna talk about us not
really too much concerned about what
they do and talk about them
because everybody's gonna you know pump
them up and that's great
and they ain't deserving of that because
of what they're able to do in the winds
but
um look man we clicking on all cylinders
we have full sprint
and this sale has never been higher than
what it is right now
um it's like black pearl taking seat
we're wide open
and and i say this and i humbly say it
just we ready we are ready and
um we looking forward to it and so
i don't like i said i don't want to take
anything from them and what they do
because they're a great football team
and
and we're just working to get there so
well i see you know i saw number 24 take
off to the end zone i first
split second thought it was you know you
because you know the old number
but what about what about that taryn
johnson kid just taking
taken to the house 101 yards in that
game there
tj has been improving every single week
and he has been showing his
he has been showing out he really has
he's been showing his tail
um being able to be a run for us in a
nickel coming in and making those um
cheap tackles for us
and then going and playing the covers
and dropping covers he's really been
a weapon for us in our armor and
he's been making plays and and guys got
to now start watching out for where he's
at because he's able to
you know make a play here and there and
that's what you need to
get out there on that football field and
make these turnovers and give the ball
back to our high
flying prolific offense i'm telling you
that josh allen
at 14 i don't know but who's who's
better than them
who's living better than them right now
they are having themselves a time and
then you have cole please he was the
best light
and i just talked to him of the day i
think god's just really downplay his
game and i'm rated
like he's the best person coming off
that line i can tell you that right now
his quicks man you got to see the game
tape
and then you got smokey brown over the
top i mean all these i mean
all these guys gabe the rook coming in
and making plays he probably got more
touchdowns than all of them
and and docks and knox i mean even motor
look man we we got a lot of people and
our unsung heroes is the offensive line
so
um that coupled with a great defense and
you know you got to have a great
defense in this run that we need right
now in the playoffs
and so all of that playing with the
special teams that we have and the
coaching staff
look we're ready for any challenge so
josh i've been talking to you for a long
time uh i've been talking to you for a
long time i've been talking to you
ever since you were having you know slap
fights with odell beckham jr
okay um we have been there we have been
it we've been talking for a minute
that's what i'm basically saying
and you know and then i i i was talking
to you after you left carolina and you
wound up in washington obviously and
you're
you're in the spot you're you sound
re-energized you sound like you're
bouncing off the walls
like you're ready josh i know you said
that about 15 times in this conversation
so i'm stating the obvious but i'm
hearing it in your voice like you are
you're seeing like an uh re-energized
person
josh i'm blessed and i'm highly flavored
i keep trying to tell you that elohim
has really truly shined his light upon
us
like once was in a dark place and now
we've seen the light it's crazy i mean
like who has it better than us right now
there's only four teams and this is
a chance for us to be like a greatness
just 60 minutes of greatness right here
that's what i'm telling the guys when we
get out there we burn them ships like
it's no coming back and if you don't
have a a sense of
excitement about this i don't know what
you're here for you know this is
something where
you only get this chance so very few
often in between
like we haven't been back to this game
in five years man so
whatever thing i got i may expend it you
better believe i'm going to expend it
and whether that is you know i have to
cheer on the sideline to help my
teammates
get out there and make a play that's
what we're going to do because
you don't get this chance often one
chance away from the dance
come on rich like we're doing it
and everything so that is why you feel
this way and
we're gonna be out this whole week shoot
i wish we could play tomorrow if we
if they if they can hurry up and get
something scheduled but hey look man
sunday
just as good so we we're prepared for it
and we're ready and
um we'll be there when the time is
called and then before i let you go here
a couple more things with you josh
norman
um you know you're new obviously to the
western new york area you're seeing
bill's mafia up close and personal you
see
how the fans donated to josh allen in
the name of his
uh uh past grandmother who just passed
away
and then you saw that they put some
money in lamar's coffers
um after he got concussed and knocked
out of that game and you
are taking part in trying to raise money
for
local small mom-and-pop businesses there
in western new york
you always have i always want to uh give
you the floor about your charitable
nature and your endeavors on that and i
want to give you the floor here about
what you're doing
there in western new york josh yeah um
look i i think that you know it's been a
bust going around
but first and foremost i want to tip my
hats off to you know
bill's mafia man like dude who has a
better
like fan base from these guys i know
it's a lot of them out there
but man they got they give money out
like it's
you know you're going to the store right
now and you see some kids here you go go
get candy
the next come out here you go go get
candy
i'm telling you they closing up on two
million dollars that deal mobby has
given to
you know organizations and outreach
things as you said josh
allen won just recently they've done
something to lamar
jackson and um my buffalo the
little business blitz that we was doing
um
we teamed up with the uh mayor's office
um with
my non-private organization in stars 24
and how we was given
back um was what not really
i was giving back grants to the people
that was
pretty much struggling in this you know
endeavor like
from colgate 19. you know um they was
closing out
the the businesses during that time and
that was like something we must do
to help them out and so we just started
it's fun
and hopefully people can donate it to it
and it started to pick up and pick up
and pick up more steam and so
now we was closing in to surrounding six
hundred thousand dollars
wow and we'll be able to give away to um
small businesses that need
anywhere upwards of twenty five hundred
dollars and so therefore we were able to
help out
you know people that's actually in
buffalo and
actually give them something to look
forward to going into the 21
um year so that's that's all we was you
know helping to do so we're trying to be
you know champions on the field
champions off the field and i think when
you build that
you know ingredients all in one you can
do it all man so
that's something that that reached out
to me that i always wanted to do
and help the people here in western new
york
for sure starswithaz24.org
buffalo business blitz to be part of
what josh is talking about and i want to
give you
one last uh moment here to pound the
table for leslie frazier you know he's
interviewing
um and and what type of uh coach he can
be in this league you have seen
you've been coordinated by him this year
uh up close and personal
uh like you want to pound the table for
coach frazier
there it is
[Laughter]
you're right i love it man
is the man like he is so cool he's like
a cool
grandpa like he's just really really
like he never
gets high or low he just stay even
killed and he gives his messages
and speeches and he gets you fired up
man really really do because
you want to play for a guy like that he
knows what he's doing
you know he knows what he's doing and
the fact is you come in with the same
juice and the same energy every week
and that's just something to be said i
mean it truly is
when you look at a guy like that and his
resume throughout the years
um shoot if he has something going on i
know i'll be
being on the table to be the first one
to go out there and look where he's
gonna be
landing because that guy right there he
he knows his game he knows how to play
it
and even give you a little speech on him
like so
he said he wanted ten touchdowns at the
end of the season right
defensive touchdowns against the season
so guys just
talked about it i was like huh yeah
right liz like you know 10 touchdowns
that's unheard of
i said okay guys going through we didn't
have no touchdowns
after weeks i don't know um 12 maybe
or however karen johnson
oh 13 taran joshua made the first play
turned it back pick six turn around
again another pick six came and then
guess what um that was from um
jerry hughes and then turn around i had
to pick six the miami game
and then turn around taryn johnson just
made another pick six
so listen here we are almost halfway
there to our goal so
now people starting to believe i love it
so this is great man it's truly great to
you know have a dc like that
to be able to um motivate the guys and
plus
he told you you're traveling with tyree
kill this week right that's what he told
you
you you're traveling with the cheetah
josh yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right wherever 10 goes i see 29 is
what it is wherever 10 goes i see 29.
so it is this weekend i don't want to
give you the game plan but
yeah man yeah yeah yeah absolutely
i mean if you've run with the bulls you
can handle you can handle the cheetah
right
you know what i mean vegeta hey i like
how you did that
this is what i do for a living and put
it all together right
yes you have hurdled a bull
in pamplona you can handle a cheetah in
kansas city josh norman
fact hey man it's the kingdom of animals
correct
that's the kingdom that's where we go to
kingdom
i love it josh you're the man thanks for
the time i really appreciate it i always
loved uh
chomping it up with you josh really
appreciate it really
yeah it has been asking a great time we
gotta get back to see you soon all these
things
blow over here yep absolutely and you
come here you'll see her you'll see your
photograph on the wall josh because
that's the way we roll here
you said you wanted it on there and we
have done that yeah i was in front of
you guys so i was just like hey look man
i appreciate the honor
you got it you take care josh i look
forward to seeing you on sunday and then
uh for your sake beyond
thank you yes indeed you guys be blessed
and have a good one all right you bet
the one
and only josh norman of the buffalo
bills here in the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here